et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Mouloud mansouris bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'être là
vous êtes vous avez plusieurs cascades
dans celles de producteurs de musique
qui avec votre association qui s'appelle
foodjo ça fait une quinzaine d'années
que vous intervenez en prison pour y
faire entrer la musique et le rap plus
spécifiquement vous y avez organisé en
prison des concerts des ateliers et là
vous avez monté pour la seconde fois ou
la deuxième fois un projet qui s'appelle
Star Academy un album de rap fait par
des détenus et des rappeurs français on
va regarder quelques images d'une série
documentaire qui est consacrée au projet
et qui va bientôt être diffusé sur
France Télévision et on en parle juste
après
notre envie donc c'est d'enregistrer un
projet donc de rap réellement ici on va
prendre les mecs les plus motivés mais
ça va être hyper intensif dire si je
vois que vous êtes pas sérieux machin je
vous dire direct
[Musique]
j'ai pas te lâcher donc en fait si tu
veux être tranquille dans ton coin opéra
voilà série en 5 épisodes qui sera
diffusé à partir de jeudi sur France
Télévisions on est à Fresnes dans l'une
des plus grandes prisons de France et
près de Paris en région parisienne
racontez-nous ce que c'est que
l'acheteur Academy pourquoi ce nom
d'abord
on a fait à peu près le même principe on
fait un casting en prison on choisit une
dizaine une dizaine de détenus et à la
fin on garde vraiment le meilleur les
plus les plus motivés et ceux qui peut
qui peuvent poser sur un album avec des
gros artistes de la scène du rap
français
ça veut dire prison je crois en argot
alors de l'écriture aux enregistrements
en passant par les tournages de clip
tout se fait à l'intérieur de Fred ouais
vraiment de A à Z tout cette fois-ci on
a réussi à tout faire à Fresnes jusqu'au
clip et ça c'est ce qu'on avait pas pu
faire sur le premier
fifou qui a fait la pochette de l'album
est venu en prison shooter les détenus
Chris Makari tony Danza qui ont réalisé
les clips pareils enfin vraiment tout a
été fait en prison et les featuring sont
venus enregistrer en prison avec avec
des détenus alors c'est la deuxième fois
que vous le faites donc là peut-être que
les détenus connaissaient plus le projet
quand vous êtes revenus mais les
premières fois que vous avez parlé de ce
projet quel a été leur leur réaction aux
détenus la toute première fois où la
première fois ou même pour celui-ci
l'album en fait je pense qu'ils seront
pas tout de suite compte de ce qu'on va
ce qu'on va faire ils disent ouais il va
deux mecs Tony et moi arriver on leur
dit ouais on va faire un album de rap
avec
il pensait que il pensait que ça serait
une petite activité comme comme il en
existe dans toutes les prisons en fait
et petit à petit ils ont vu qu'on était
là quand même sur le long terme parce
qu'on est resté quand même presque un an
avec eux et ils ont commencé à avoir les
artistes défilés et là ils sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait un truc très
sérieux qui se préparait et ils se sont
vraiment bougé pour pour faire un album
de qualité et qu'est-ce que la musique
et le rap en particulier permet voilà
musique en général ça adoucit les mœurs
on sait mais le rap c'est une culture
qui est qui vachement présente chez les
jeunes et en détention aussi c'est la
musique la plus écoutée en France donc
forcément là-bas aussi et c'est une
musique qui les représente depuis le
début le rap c'est un phénomène qui
vient de la rue qui représente des gens
de la rue et malheureusement en prison
c'est c'est beaucoup ces jeunes là qui
qui sont là-bas et donc avec les
activités qu'on propose c'est vraiment
les représenter qui se sentent qui sont
pas oublier là-bas et
voilà du coup c'est une activité où ils
sont motivés et ils lâche pas le projet
quoi ils deviennent
acclamés aller voir un concert par
exemple avant d'arriver en prison ouais
c'est ça sur les concerts il y a plein
de mecs qui viennent nous voir c'est la
première fois que je veux un concert et
en fait c'est chômé donc voilà si on
peut leur offrir ça c'est cool alors
l'album donc à 21 titres je crois sort
en fin de semaine il y a des chansons
qui ont déjà circuler dans celles qu'on
va entendre maintenant c'est pas une
petite chanson vous dit que c'était un
vrai projet elle a été vu je crois plus
de 2 millions de fois
[Musique]
tous les soirs je te t'en parler bientôt
tu me le soleil de qualité
[Musique]
et donc de plusieurs détenus avec lui ce
clip là spécifiquement a fait polémique
notamment chez les syndicats de
surveillance il est concomitant en tout
cas sa diffusion de l'une des polémiques
de l'été koh-lanthes une activité de
karting organisée dans cette prison à
Fresnes pour les détenus dont on a
beaucoup parlé une fausse polémique
[Musique]
est-ce que ça a dit que une partie des
Français ou peut-être de la classe
politique française avait une vision
quasiment exclusivement punitive quoi de
la prison ceux qui connaissent pas le le
principe de la prison ok il y a il y a
il y a le principe de punition mais
aussi le principe d'insertion de
l'insertion on doit préparer les détenus
à ressortir meilleur que ce qu'ils
étaient sinon bah ça va être un problème
pour la société de recroiser ces gens
dans la rue si on les rend plus sauvages
que qu'il ne l'était
et ça un projet comme l'acheteur Academy
ça ça permet quoi d'avancer sur ça sur
la réinsertion
une porte de sortie vers vers la musique
en plutôt d'entrée ils ont ils ont vu
tous les tous les tous les gens qui
organisent un projet comme ça c'est à
dire des producteurs des beatmakers des
artistes des gens qui mettent en scène
les artistes sur scène etc etc donc
aujourd'hui savent ce que c'est que le
milieu de la musique ils sont en promo
tous les soirs sur Skyrock
c'est des cocotes minutes les prisons
donc on les enferme on les c'est un
milieu qui broie et à un moment donné
comme dans toutes civilisations les gens
peuvent se révolter et si les détenus
autant violents qui soient se révoltent
et quand il se retrouve tous dans la rue
comme dans des pays qui sont qui sont
aussi peu développés que nous dans les
prisons ben ça pète quoi en 2020 la
France a été condamnée par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
avait sommé l'état de réduire le
surpeuplement en carcéral vous lisez
150% à Fresnes en moyenne sur le
territoire c'est 117% d'occupation des
prisons et d'améliorer les conditions
matérielles de détention ça c'était il y
a deux ans entre temps il y a une covid
on sait que le covid en prison ça a été
absolument catastrophique et rien n'a
changé depuis ou presque
je sais que que c'était encore plus dur
pendant le covid parce qu'ils avaient
même plus les parloirs ou alors des
parleurs vitrées plus de contact avec
l'extérieur les activités étaient
bloquées mais vous dites 2020 mais en
fait ils sont je crois qu'ils sont
condamnés tous les ans par la Cour
européenne et en fait s'en foutent ils
payent des amendes donc nous payons des
amendes parce que c'est nos impôts qui
payent quoi ça pour vous d'une société
qui
[Musique]
laisse penser qu'on est
française elle a pas mal de mots et ça
c'est c'est un endroit qui est
complètement caché donc parfois une fois
par an on parle un peu de la prison là
on a on a profité du sujet koh-lanthèse
pour concentrer toutes les voix sur la
prison puis pendant un an on va plus en
parler l'année prochaine on retrouvera
notre truc c'est comme ça c'est c'est un
endroit qui est caché les gens ne
connaissent pas donc c'est pas grave ils
sont en prison c'est qu'ils ont fait des
conneries on s'en fout dans ce tableau
c'est noir il y a des gens de lumière
dont vous êtes et je crois que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé bien sûr avec le
directeur de la prison de Fresnes qui
pour le coup un peu à rebours de
l'image qu'on peut avoir et plutôt voilà
à porteur de ces projets et vous
soutient
la prison lui il a il était je crois
gardant de prison avant d'être directeur
donc il sait ce que c'est que la prison
est il fait en sorte que sa prison elle
pète pas et je pense que qui le fait
bien la preuve il a pas sauté en général
quand il y a quand on a des polémiques
un peu comme ça il y a un fusil qui
saute et il est toujours là-bas c'est
qu'il travaille bien je Star Academy 2
il y aura acheté Academy 3
ans pour faire le deuxième c'est des
projets qui sont dures à monter donc on
verra je crois que vous voulez aussi
monter des cours de cuisine avec un
autre petit jeu de mots pas mal
un truc comme ça ouais un truc
j'aimerais bien aller vers la cuisine
j'aime bien ça
sort c'est l'objet donc d'une série
documentaire réalisé par Sarah Marx qui
sera diffusé vendredi sur France
Télévisions ben bon on souhaite bonne
chance à cet album merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu nous en parler ce matin on
va se quitter en images et en musique
merci Mouloud mon souris et à très
bientôt sur le plateau de Paris
je suis là dans ta chute police
stratégique cassé dans le port huchu les
espèces de sale brut attends frérot
laisse-moi couper une minute empiler
comme dans Tetris quotidien et très
triste dans ta playlist les poches qui
servent bloque la promenade on fait
bosser les cerises j'ai pour desserts
les donneurs les donneurs pour ramasser
la petite cuillère frère il y a pas de
frère il y a pas de frère ça fait
longtemps comme Federer envoie-le oh mon
sang moneylo servait-il la déco reprend
les logos pardonne tous les échos dans
une cellule
à l'intérieur je vois qui simule pète ça
rentrera dans la cabeza tu penses à
survie je pense pas à Bella
dans une